what are the things to be considered
even if you are planning to buy a
machine or if you bought a machine what
to do next and what are the precautions
has to be done with respect to Technical
and non-technical growth right
so uh the microbes it's not in one place
we all know it's there any anywhere and
everywhere you name it data industry
like say you walk the way wherever you
walk me in the Park Theater school
college or office everything it is there
right so there is no we are living in
micro World rather than they living in
our world that's what we see right and
uh how do we understand is it easy to
understand so since we are seeing it
almost everywhere and anywhere right
what is the possibility to understand it
in a better form right of course the
microbiology term is not something new
but once the genomics comes in picture
the way we started to look into
microbiology is very very different
right because we came to know many new
things and how it has been done apart
from apart from the normal traditional
microbiology test when we do NGS
specifically what are the things we are
going to get and what are the equipments
which will be using we are going to see
them right uh so there are two kind of
sequences generally in market right one
is a bin stock another one is a uh
probably the production based so when I
say bin stop what does that it can do
when stops are made for specifically
smaller organism sequences so as you can
see the list in this right
you get a pointer
so these are all the applications these
are all the machines right so uh most of
the not only in India across the globe
if people are having limited sample B
clinical or non-clinical they are mostly
starting with my C what is my sick is
basically it's a small bench top which
allows you to produce minimum of 15 GB
output when I say GB it's gigabases here
so as far as uh the wet lab is concerned
you will never ever speak about the
bytes which is a computer at all right
so the total output which we get from
the machine is basically 15 giga basis
right so uh again every machine will be
having their own uh set of
specifications in specific so if I use
this machine how many samples I can load
how much depth I will be going uh how
many uh probably what are the things I
can understand with respect to
application also suppose example here as
you can see here
thank you
yes right so here these are all the
applications right uh so as you can see
these dots represents whatever
application we can do with respect to
machines so broader machines can do
anything everything anything and
everything when I say anything and
everything it means including your
smaller organisms beta fungus virus
bacterial or any kind of microbes and
the humans but when we say brain stops
humans we can do only targeted panels
but microbes you can do uh like even if
it is a less number of samples even the
bench top will solve the problem so in
that case mysig is mostly preferred for
small whole genome sequencing of
microbes and viral right so of course
you can do everything it's based on the
sample load but the optimized size when
you say not so less or not so more which
is something average or the middle mid
level mysq is preferred right
so again you can see so what are the
application generally used from the
microbes World either it is a whole
genome or probably even sexiness
metagenomics and or the full like the
shortcut metagenomics or meta
transcriptomics right so these are
things generally done as far as
metagenomics is concerned if the sample
load is lesser then that can be done in
my C if it is more then the bigger
machines are growth so when I say so why
the more and less comes in picture very
often because the costing is involved
right so how do people plan the project
or probably study the total uh like say
if you have a data set or if you're
planning to study something first thing
will be estimating how many samples you
are going to process how many controls
are going to be there how many uh treat
let's say in your case if it is a Time
series data sets or if it's a control
versus normal you'll be planning
everything which machine fits in which
flow cell goes in what are the religions
has to be purchased everything should be
planned for rent right for that these
days table will be useful it's like an
easy probably the reference this is for
the bench stops